I'm a little heartbroken because we did
have some great plans Jennifer Lopez
opens up about putting her wedding with
fiance Alex Rodriguez on hold due to the
corona virus pandemic I'm also like you
know what God has a bigger plan the
50-year old world of dance judge
appeared on Tuesday's episode of The
Today Show and opened up to Hoda Kotb
about postponing her I Do's we just have
to wait and see maybe it's gonna be
better I have to believe that it will be
as for when JLo and a rod will be able
to have their ceremony
well the superstar says that's all still
up in the air it's disappointing on one
level you know after the Super Bowl and
after world of dance after we finished
filming it
you know I plan to take time off which
is what we're doing kind of right now
but at the same time you know we had a
lot of plans for this summer and this
year but everything kind of on hold
right now
et caught up with a former baseball star
back in April and he revealed how he and
Jen had been coordinating with their
personal teams trying to figure out how
to move forward with their wedding
planning we had a meeting on zoom with
our core with Benny and Lisa and Elaine
and I kind of just going over what the
next 12 months looks like and we have
like three or four different variations
of how that can look whether that's
going on tour next summer the other
plans you talked about and movies that
you're planning is such a fluid world I
mean usually when you underwrite a year
whether scheduling or financially you
never think about is gonna stop like
this so we're having to be very fluid
think on our feet and just think very
proactively but at the same time I think
the most important thing for everybody
is to practice great discipline stay at
home we have to do this together and
every person counts that's the way we're
gonna beat this thing is together and
the former New York Yankee opened up
about what quarantine has been like for
them I'm actually thrilled to be home
because I'm never home so I'm making the
best out of it we're playing wiffle ball
we're playing chess we're playing
checkers
we're playing Monopoly we're playing
and for us to have dinner with the kids
every day is a dream as for JLo she
echoed all that on today life in our
house I think is like you know
everybody's the kids are in virtual
school um Alex and I are doing a lot of
zoom calls a lot of working and and
that's it that's pretty much it
I mean what's nice is we get to have
dinner together every night and I gotta
tell you I I love that that part I love
[Music]